Khloe Kardashian is filling heartbroken
after report says her ex Lamar Odom is
still struggling with alcohol issues
according to a report Lamar was thrown
off a delta airlines red-eye flight to
New York Monday after being drunk and
vomiting in the bathroom for months
Khloe had been trying to get her ex to
go to rehab and on Tuesday when a fan
told her she can't save every soul her
response but we like to try ET reached
out to the airline who told us Delta
takes customer privacy very seriously
and declined to comment further a source
close to Khloe tells ET the reality star
is very concerned but doesn't know what
else she can do at this point quote
she's tried everything she can to help
him the man was on his deathbed and she
helped him get a second chance at life
if that didn't wake him up what will
Kevin Frazier spoke with Lamar in April
he appeared hopeful about his future
what's next for you Lamar um get back on
the court are you gonna try and play
again yeah I still got it
you
you